i'm sorry you guys have probably noticed
my stomach's a little more sensitive
lately
so if you wouldn't mind wearing a little
less perfume
and if your lunch is especially pungent
maybe have it in the break room we would
really appreciate it pam is constantly
throwing up because of the pregnancy if
she eats something the fetus doesn't
like she is screwed
it's amazing a three ounce fetus is
calling the shots
it's so badass
phyllis
um if you could switch to a different
soap just for a month or two yours is
kind of perfumey now this is getting
ridiculous oh gee i'm sorry i guess i
missed the meeting where we all voted
for you to get pregnant
no
i reserve the right to peel my
hard-boiled eggs at my desk all morning
i look forward to my afternoon cigars
and i am not stopping for anybody
i don't think i'm asking for too much
i guess it's just the end of courtesy in
the workplace
watching people get sick
always makes me sick and
well frankly soda's talking about it so
wow
eyeballs rats baths vampire teeth boom
vampire teeth good
spiderwebs done
fake blood capsules
oh they didn't have any
really
that's gross i love it
daddy's daughter anna's getting divorced
i hate to say i told you so but i told
you so
you know we should fix her up with
bernice's son what's his name the doctor
oh vince and he's not a doctor he's a
pharmacist although that might appeal to
anne
pop
craig
you're such a cracker
forget ann who should we fix him up with
huh oh now sal you know i'm still
getting over the tragic loss of my wife
she was such a strong female woman with
nice heavy breasts who's that
oh that's my neighbor hey larry ah hey
grab greg ah that was it
i'm not sure why i have so much trouble
remembering probably because our
relationship is so casual
morning ladies hi
uh do a lap without me i need to talk to
larry about an issue with our shared
fence larry i need to talk to you about
an issue with our shared fence yes i
also need to discuss this shared fence
issue with you okay they're out of
earshot why are you up so early no
reason just excited to face a new day oh
because ever since we've been down here
you've been a little
depressed
have i
don't eat the burrito
wow what happened in there i don't know
stink in there my god
what it what is that
oh i don't know is that a bird
i don't think it's a bird oh god
how could that happen how could
right in the middle of the carpet what's
going on um somebody vomited right in
the middle of the carpet in my office
i don't think that's vomit check it out
me check it out
[Applause]
don't be a wuss just get known holding
your coffee
tell me what it is oh that's really good
what is it
michael what is it no just tell me what
it is michael i i gotta get out of here
i can't hold my breath that long open
the door up
it smelled terrible
oh i cannot believe a pipe burst and
left that there there's no burst pipe
how do you know that what is it then hey
guys
somebody making soup
so we've been called out to this hiking
trail because there's some reports that
some teenagers are digging bags of dog
poop out of the trash and having dog
boot fights
i don't believe it
oh my god it's real
uh yeah i'm not gonna i'm not gonna go
deal with this i'm leaving
hey
hey
hello boys
i am leslie knope i work for the
department of parks and recreation
okay
all right
okay
that's disgusting
why would you think this was fun ah
really oh really really oh hey hey do
you like it
okay here we go who wants it
missed it
yeah
actually this is a little fun
this is fun
welcome to the jimmy jabs we play for
pride we play for the phone numbers of
rosa's friends but most importantly we
play to watch amy lose nope this is my
year it's my year too please don't align
yourself with me why not neither of you
have ever come close to winning you're
exactly the same just a couple of
santiagos
but the real prize is
the winchester 3000. the only chair in
the precinct with minimal staining good
lumbar support and no broken rolly
wheels over to you gina thank you jake
okay guys as usual the loser of each
event is eliminated from the games the
winner gets a bonus in the final round
our first event is
the mouth-a-thon
in front of you is month-old chinese
food from the fridge go ahead and eat as
much as you can stomach on your mark get
set
wahlberg
[Music]
oh
i can't do this to my mouth she's the
love of my life charles is eliminated
off i think this ball of soup is off i'm
out i can do this
i want to win so bad oh great here quick
let me take a picture oh that's so cute
you've got a little bit of mold on the
tip of your nose
i tried i tried but he is unbeatable
you guys know this is free
jerry god gross
oh
jerry
guys
oh god oh i think he might be having a
heart attack what
are you serious oh so much stuff is
happening right now call 9-1-1 okay
just breathe okay you're going to be
fine
no jeez in a dinosaur dysphoric jerry
get a grip sorry guys
[ __ ] apology not accepted stop talking
[ __ ] i wish i could stop smelling dude
seriously jerry did you eat farts for
lunch tom jerry's having a heart attack
oh no i didn't know that jerry you okay
scully where are you on digitizing the
old case files as of yesterday i'm
officially one percent done
why are you smiling that's nothing oh
there's thousands of cases and for each
one i have to fill out 200 little box
thingies on 50 different screens at
least you get to sit on your butt all
day that's actually the worst part my
doctor said i have an anal canyon
scully why are you always telling us
about your disgusting body i don't see
anything that's because it's all wart
that's interesting wow it's a little
early for ice cream nowadays it's never
too early for ice cream gem
but we didn't have any ice cream
so this is mayonnaise and black olives
oh it's comfort food all right
god yo michael this old donna thing is
gonna be okay you just stop beating
yourself up i know well i hope you're
right we'll see what dwight says why do
we have to see what dwight says because
i have him investigating her i'm waiting
for a text up michael no no no no no no
undo that undo that it's too late to
undo it i need to know otherwise this
thing is going to spiral out of a muck
michael okay i'm i'm going to talk
straight to you because i think you need
to hear it michael this is so disgusting
stop eating it
you